you
here we go to those who take part in
this let's have some fun here create a
new tournament here we go it's called
the Jones the Jones arena jump in fast
very fast we're waiting for nineteen
players fifteen ten eleven you get the
idea
five four three two tournament starting
here we go okay I'm not gonna go berserk
hitting that uh there's a little berserk
button if you hit that your time is
chopped in half and what happens well if
you win you get a an extra point an
extra point is what you get
let's take here and kick this night
around at some stage maybe preserve my
night with h3 what's that move about I
don't understand it let's go here oh
that's a mouse slipper and a half isn't
it tried to castle I could relate
everybody's done that if you played
enough chess
Oh what are they setting out fishing
pole stuff maybe that was not a mouse
lip they were just pretending
oh I mouse lipped cuz really h5 Bishop
here some kind of some kind of what that
they were fake Mouse slipping maybe
that's what we could say it is let's pin
this knight and then here actually
that's a game over move isn't it you can
stop this this is gonna be very painful
isn't it I can't even pile up here now
let's do that let's hammer away at that
guy yeah that's a big trouble you
actually I have rook here
let's take like this excuse me the rook
is hit and I feel like I don't even want
to take it now I want to take it on my
next move I have mates right here on f7
I have f2 guarded they resigned back to
tournament it's it's a tough adjustment
but uh they have returned to tournament
but I almost always end up saying back
to tournament back determine it will
stay let's try the Sicilian against W
young all right I gotta go faster I feel
like I can't go as fast sometimes they
are flying look at how much time they
spent very little you need to slow down
let's keep a knight on board I don't
like playing with this isolated pawn but
what can you do make it work there's a
pin he's got to go back here ah probably
no no let's try this some of a minority
isn't that dropping F - I like that F 2
squared
I like this discovery zone discovery
land watch out Queen is officially
cooked and that Knights in a pin the
farm is falling I don't know I don't
know that's one of those lines I'll look
back on and say did I really say that
let's go here that's game - a mini a
mini mini streak a mini streak alright
let's roll with the d4 c4 why am I going
with actually d4 and c4 I should be
trying the fishing pull from the the
white side I could do that
it's definitely illegal legal it's
definitely legal maybe I should have
tried h4 right there let's throw a
question I'll take here and build my
center these are just imaginary doubled
pawns they will undone at some point
after this capture castles e4 Knight d2
e4 try and take advantage of this pin
pawn push I could take here immediately
let's get opposite their queen e4 next
maybe uh-oh let's go here that's the
square that was given up with the blacks
last move so let's occupy that and
defend here and let's open stuff up why
not I want this
file to open up I could take care and
then do this let's push him around then
here where is he going
oh he can't go here and he's actually
dead isn't he gonna take this pawn down
I always have this check if there's some
tempo against my Bishop he's officially
out of squares he's still out of squares
there's no reason to take him right away
just save my bishop and I'm back to
throwing a punch at that Knight pawn
push I could give a check play here
probably the check and then take here
and the night is still cooked they
resigned back to tournament who did this
guy just finish up here
maybe we're gonna get paired up maybe
yes we are paired up this is an
important one he's he's top up there is
the top dog gotta go fast all right
let's get this out here the Stonewall
they're setting up my bishop here and
castle and okay that would have been a
really really really bad Mouse lip let's
do this oh I could jump in here my
bishops there to defend I also have the
f4 square and they're gonna take my
knight I want to kick this Knight out of
here this is a good home for my pieces
but this one not so much
let's do this here next maybe I don't
want to take this Knight I helped them
to develop I'm also threatening here
difficult to defend rook here to here I
could do this and then maybe this ooh
you guys should do this first yeah let's
do this I have this Square covered
let's break do I want to take with my
rook ooh
let's take now and
[Music]
this is kind of scary I guess here now
they're gonna take here and do this they
don't have any time on a sack the
exchange where do their time go do this
on the rook here Queen trade they miss
it yeah they didn't have any time to
they resigned back to tournament yeah I
think they were down on time that's why
they were not able to react to those
like Queen threats and stuff alright
here we go let's see if we could uh and
get a fishing pole going on here
what would a 30-minute tournament be
without at least one one try for a
fishing hole even if it's not successful
I have to get it out of my system is
what I'm getting at it's a thinker of a
position Knight g4 incoming let's still
do this I get the H file let's do this
and then this probably should have held
off a little bit
castles let's do this Bishop here next
probably do this actually now let's do
this right now so there's it's probably
just imaginary play that I have in the H
file yeah I'll take with the pawn
another Knight is a bit sensitive isn't
he you got a really sensitive Knight
there don't you okay watch out for
Knight b6 that's a dangerous dangerous
square here let's hit the knight let's
go here actually I'm on this tonight has
to go back maybe I put pressure then on
c4 dropping this but my rook is gonna be
a super-duper active piece pacman mode
soon Knights hit everything's hit this
is hit twice V pawn hit why are you not
moving rook here get rid of the pesky
Knight I'm dropping upon
let's go here push he has passed run run
again go here okay I'm definitely losing
objectively but this is a win on time
one point six not enough time there's no
way can't do it back to tournament times
sometimes is all you have and that's
actually the usual case for me that's
the usual case man how are we doing with
the standings 16 14 12 12 we have this
little sidebar here so we can keep track
of it a little bit let's do this they're
gonna stop night here let's make use of
it throw the Queen back then get d5 in
all right we go back not sure what to
make of that little time situation here
that little back-and-forth that we had
let's play in the Queen side I was ready
to drop my rook with rip b8 all right
they're gonna go after my king let's do
this bishop here scary move to deal with
and now I'm gonna be winning something
of rook in this case let's take here
open the B file first chip away a little
bit more throw my knight in to c5 let's
first get here and I'm okay with this
move I just have to take some good care
over my dark squares let's do this
I want to get this square for my knight
and I'll do well to cover this square
now that's dropping everything Knights
hit let's take this pawn eliminate this
guy take here one little moment there to
pause I have this square covered let's
do
I want to take here next whoa take here
soon 13 seconds get out of that I don't
have any time
Oh 10 seconds run where are the Queen
trades here whoa really
I got the rook go fast six seconds come
back over here easier to do with my pond
losing my breath oh my goodness I hate
that so much I really do I really do
hate that I just taste the wind right
out of me
every time kidnapped I can't shake that
for whatever the reason I hold my breath
and bullet says there's some crazy
effects on you yeah that's just how it
is
oh my goodness okay I got a strike at
these guys here right I mean can I
really just let that palm treo sit there
all right I was ready to drop my queen
let's do this I guess here and then f5
ah you're reminding me that my c7 pond
is tender tender I think that's oh now I
get to clamp down on the queenside here
I think that's a term that Maurice
Ashley is so I hope he's okay with that
you use that to describe a certain
position certain soft points in a
position he's that word tender so I'm
stealing that stealing that term from
our niece
all right um can I get back to over here
okay let's push now I was fearful that
because of a knight jumping in here
let's do this maybe just push I'll be
looking on the clock let's get this
Knight involved I mean really what was
he doing oh my bishop is an animal now
my dark square Bishop King h7 let's take
here King h7 rook g8 to start here let's
just triple up I'm hitting the bishop
they missed that seven seconds let's
just take him here pretty much no matter
what unless rook takes pawn
welcome my bishop do to be a pest I
should have maybe done this immediately
Oh back to tournament they're down on
time twenty five
what's the twenty five twenty four
twenty one okay I was ready to say less
than a minute less than a minute
remaining of course each side has less
than a minute sixteen minutes remain in
the tournament are not quite at the
halfway point so I have a small pond
center a little bit of a Hedgehog thing
going on here Brooke c1 off to maybe
move my knight right away I have this
move let's get a flight square in first
am I not just winning upon mass
exchanges I'll take with my bishop and I
have this coverage still and just take
once let's go here and not really a big
fan of doing it and weakens the light
squares but it should be quite all right
I don't think there's a way to take
advantage of that alright capture like
this Queen trade I need to be a bit
careful let's do this
get on the open file not afraid of that
Queen check actually should I be let's
throw this in
centralize the Queen let's push this
pawn he is doubled their King is
actually ready to get mated they
threaten f4 and that's GG back
determined actually that was the leader
I was forgetting that that was a really
big game 20 because he was up
28:25 21 20 is where we stand so far Oh
14 minutes remain not getting paired up
how many people are in this Oh
eighty-eight players are in this one all
right we gotta get a tournament that has
more than 88 should be more c5 break at
the dark squares put my dark squared
Bishop to use trying to help him out
with this break just more generally
speaking breaking up that pawn duo I
take here and I run c6 first they're not
moving okay I'm gonna dropping upon with
that right yeah I'm getting a pun I'm
getting more than a pawn now getting a
piece okay I'm up two pieces now let's
just develop why why not take a third
piece with you oh I should have just
taken a third piece let's just develop
because developing is better than
winning another piece oh my goodness
back to basics take three pieces take
free pieces rook takes mating two rook
takes here it's still gonna be a matin
too soon whatever
whatever let's do this I have a flight
square time less than 10 seconds for
them why not take that a pond let's take
them now
and then hunt this pond down and push
here I have good coordination keep
marching with this guy get him up there
they're down on time back to tournament
32 25 30 - 27 25 24 29 t players are
here now alright let's go with d4 c4
let's do an exchange
I know get some quick moves in here I
didn't want to allow that to happen
they Mouse lip - they thought I was
gonna capture let's get here
isn't this the maybe Bishop back and
then have the Queen line up in the
battery would have been better
45 okay
they're gonna flop a knight right in
there let's do this get my Queen off of
that alright let's try this still go for
it I have a center I'm looking to take
and then push let's take here take this
night I guess throw that guy up there
are very active rook
um I don't like that move okay I'm
dropping this I guess maybe you had this
though hang on let's see I'm on the rook
and this move I don't know I meant I'm
on the night I missed that definitely
welcome this move may threats
looking to take let's stay here stay
active oh I just dropped upon trades
this is a very bad technique oh I can
take my pawn six seconds I could have
taken the rook I could have taken the
rook they try to time burner oh my
goodness I can't breathe I can never
breathe oh my goodness barely barely oh
man it's just a rat race you're just
around at that point it doesn't matter
if it doesn't make sense just make a
move find illegal move and go with it
and if you even if you just know how to
play a game of legal chess and you're
like yeah but I don't know any strategy
bolla is your game sometimes at least
find the legal move and make it alright
let's kick this night around
oh I weaken that square I want to get on
this dog and I'll flush the King here I
don't like my Roca nuf to save them here
I don't like how I'm playing this very
weakening moves here we're gonna have a
queen trade let's go here
Oh Tritan you take the night and then
here I don't even realize that right
away
the queen is cooked they resigned back
to tournament forty forty twenty nine
twenty eight twenty six eight less than
nine minutes remain uh the monkey star
didn't I play him before oh let's stop
the pin where's the light square Bishop
going now alright let's do this
let's do this and then that some of the
better commentary around this and that
that Asian elitist comes right out of me
let's do this and then that most
educational words you could express
really alright mass exchanges on the e5
square yes and I could pull it let's
glue my queen in here now she'll be
challenged we're gonna dance a little
bit but I'm gonna sneak over here let my
queen be a pest just a little bit maybe
I could fix my queen right here I've
challenged I have a better queen
position so now she's kind of like a
fiend cut out Bishop not the brightest
piece mmm I guess this I thought I am
fixing upon on a light square I'm
stopping them from getting their uh
their pawns rolling I don't know if this
is such a good idea let me take a make a
u-turn here I just said my queen is
better now I'm offering a Queen's change
make up your mind you're gonna keep your
queen or not okay they have more pawns
fixed on light squares now I have no
pawns fix on light squares and I should
have taken upon I still could take that
pawn and now I could pile up on that guy
I'm breaking through on that guy all
right let's take here push next trade
bishops alright he's gone defend my
second maybe defend him some more I am
up upon my rook is ideally placed push
get my King active King active can you
active push get the other pawn roll
come over here King and pawn ending is
winning let's play here push my C pawn
next actually let's do this oh they're
down on time I only had three point nine
left
44:35 44 35 32
okay let's reinforce this and just get
these pieces out really quick maybe I
should have stopped Bishop g4 okay I
don't have to worry about that now okay
I think this is a favorable structural
change Knight here maybe you're right
away would have been better let's try
and fix that this structure here it's
broken down this b4 is the threat I
sniffed that one out let's try this move
my knight hit that pond let's build up a
little bit first get my rook working
he's not needed over here flight square
maybe Bishop here at some stage Knight a
for right now know maybe reposition to
this square I'm on c5 oh and that's
coming now with the fork there goes the
rook let's secure my e4 pawn next Queen
trades actually let's have my pawn
defend upon my rooks unprotected a4
might be on board with beating to be 2
if that was the case h5 I should have
stopped h5 I maybe should have played h5
themselves Bishop h3 King here less than
34 black let's come here trade a little
bit we're still pretty even on the clock
I don't like that the bishop on push not
so fast drop that pond put pressure here
I want to check that pawn down they have
dark square control I need to get rid of
their dark square Bishop get out of
there
oh they missed that I'm up a full broke
and then some
all right there Knight is officially
under control cannot go anywhere they
resigned back to tournament
4835 34:34 32:28 less than five minutes
remaining
ninety-nine players are in this one
alright not getting paired up this is
the longest wait for a game I thought it
was long but I write to get another one
in here oh that's a mouse slip that's
not good
Getty Florian with tempo Knight f6
probably no take here okay Bishop here
b7 f7 big trouble get that c6 pawn as
well
97 Queen c6 rook c8 Queen a4 defends the
bishop
I like keeping my queen in that position
for too long uh I guess we'll take keep
pressure on the night in fact I should
do should have done this Bishop takes
Knight is good why not damage my
structure let's hit this rook hit the
rook again I don't want to allow them to
castle so easily
I got the rook give me the rook Bishop
takes Knight with rook c8 to follow her
oh that's me is that a mouse left or
something
no what happened just there or just then
okay
52 36 35 34 32 alright let's go with the
Kings Indian No
let's get an e5 break in challenge that
trio okay so now I could focus on these
dark squares I'm gonna look to
reposition my knight here c5 e 64 okay
if a6 I couldn't have done this so
quickly jump in here I stuff to get my
Queen night out where's she gonna go
let's do this see if they take first No
I didn't want to have to do that I give
up this square ooh that okay I'm in
trouble yeah I'm in trouble oh I have to
give up my queen
Oh No dark squares can you hold the fort
somehow dark squares I have a tricky
night I have a tricky night so there's
still hope
or is there it's my dark square bishop
up to nothing I got to keep this closed
Ron pond you're fast they only have a
second
they only have a second I'd even realize
oh my goodness
f 697 oh my goodness f 697 I totally
missed that yeah I was I was cooked
objectively in that one
I had a lien on the clock again for that
one am I gonna get paired up this next
game might not finish there's only a
minute how much time is left
I could even use a no no fry tactic who
remembers an ona fry tactic there might
have to be some explaining some people
will question no no fry what's that to
turn back the clocks for that one let's
do this so rules out night here stuff
you know you could just let your clock
tick down now let the game finish it's
sometimes a pretty good strategy rook d4
it's being sniffed right out let's
straight dark square bishop somehow
maneuver Knight to d4 one day let's get
back here Queen here okay now I get to
go here you take I get a past pun oh and
if you do that I'd lose if I forgot
about that ladder
mm excuse me 12 seconds this is this
game is not gonna finish
I made threats Queen trade not enough
time three seconds two seconds one so
this game will not count for the
tournament I at least I get the bishop
over here take that pawn
I shouldn't have dropped oh I for some
reason I was thinking they could take my
beep on so this isn't really gonna count
for anything
they just end it Oh white resigned it
didn't matter anyhow okay return the
tournament the tournament is over all
right
no confetti a hundred players took part
in this 156 final standings 56 42 38 37
34 33 and the list goes on let me let me
see who took part and that's some of the
other players all right
sometimes you well you could you could
enter it and then leave or you could
also enter late so keep in mind some of
these players might have uh they might
have started and then a left Midway or
just entered late if you're wondering
these are some of the things that could
have happened and these are withdrawals
I think there's something like that okay
yeah I think you're able to see it all
all right to the hundred of you exactly
who took part in the tournament GG's all
right
[Music]